Fachleute sind optimistisch, dass unbemannte
Flugtaxis schon sehr bald Passagiere von A
nach B bringen.
Städte wie Los Angeles, Singapur und Dubai
könnten in Pilotprojekten schon 2020 mit
kommerziellen Passagier-Drohnen durchstarten.
Aber auch in Deutschland laufen Projekte in
Sachen “Urban Air Mobility”.
Eine wichtige Modellregion ist Ingolstadt.
Ein elektrischer “City-Airbus” soll hier
bis zu vier Personen durch die Luft transportieren.
Clixoom Science & Fiction - hier gibt es täglich
spannende Science-Videos abonniert den Kanal,
nur dann verpasst ihr nichts - herzlich willkommen!
Luft-Taxis sind ja wohl der Traum aller Pendler.
Einfach einsteigen und das Ziel schnell und
ohne Stau, Umwege und Verzögerungen erreichen.
Auch die nervige Parkplatz-Suche hätte man
sich so ganz einfach gespart!
Im besten Fall sollten Flugtaxis auch noch
kostengünstig und umweltfreundlich unterwegs
sein.
So könnte wir dann vor allem in verkehrsreichen
Städten endlich aufatmen.
Denn die Situation mit den endos verstopften
Straßen wird nicht besser - im Gegenteil.
Schätzungen zufolge werden im Jahr 2030 gut
60 Prozent der Weltbevölkerung in urbanen
Regionen leben.
Das heißt, dass sich mehr als 500 Millionen
Menschen jeden Tag durch Staus auf den Straßen
quälen müssen.
Und deswegen sind sich viele Fachleute sicher,
dass der Nahverkehr in der Luft die Mobilität
der Zukunft ist!
Ein Testprojekt dazu ist gerade in der Region
Ingolstadt angelaufen und ja: Hier wird tatsächlich
das ausprobiert, was Anfang der 80er Jahre
der Hollywood-Film “Blade Runner” thematisiert
hat.
Fliegende Autos nämlich.
Konkret geht es um den sogenannten “CityAirbus”
und wie der Name schon verrät- steckt der
europäische Flugzeugbauer Airbus dahinter.
Der Mini-Airbus wird elektrisch betrieben
und ist mit vier Doppel-Rotoren ausgestattet.
Somit kann er sowohl senkrecht starten als
auch landen und dabei vier Passagiere befördern.
Und der Elektroantrieb macht den Flug nicht
nur emissionsfrei, sondern auch geräuscharm
Und “Airbus” steht damit nicht alleine
da.
Auch “Boeing” tüftelt schon lange an
der Idee der Lufttaxis, die in Zukunft gewöhnliche
Busse, Bahnen und Taxis auf dem Boden ergänzen
könnten.
Ein erster Testflug mit dem Prototypen eines
Elekto-Lufttaxi fand schon Anfang des Jahres
statt - und zwar in den USA.
Allein bei “Airbus” sind mehr als 100
Mitarbeiter an dem Bereich “Urban Air Mobility”
dran - auch das zeigt, dass das Ganze ein
wirklich großes Thema ist.
Dennoch führt der “Begriff” Taxi zunächst
auf eine falsche Fährte, denn genau genommen
handelt es sich bei solchen Luft-Taxis nicht
um Taxis, die individuelle Routen möglich
machen.
Der “CityAirbus” soll stattdessen von
fest definierten Punkten zu anderen Punkten
fliegen und Passagiere befördern.
Ein Konkurrenzmodell also zum Auto und zum
öffentlichen Nahverkehr auf der Straße.
Dabei ist die Spitzengeschwindigkeit des Airbus-Flugtaxis
von 120 Stundenkilometern mit dem eines Autos
vergleichbar.
Doch klar ist auch, dass man zumindest in
der Theorie deutlich schneller sein Ziel mit
einem solchen Fluggerät erreichen könnte.
Die Reichweite vom “CityAirbus” beträgt
50 Kilometer, womit kürzere Flüge innerhalb
einer Stadt durchaus zu bewältigen sind.
Das bestätigt auch Georg Kursell, ein Sprecher
von Airbus: “Solche Luftfahrzeuge werden
wahrscheinlich nicht von Stadt zu Stadt fliegen.”
Die ersten Praxistests werden im Sommer auf
dem Testgelände in der Nähe von Ingolstadt
starten.
Manche Fachleute gehen davon aus, dass die
Lufttaxis dann schon im Jahr 2030 zwischen
dem Flughafen München und dem Hauptbahnhof
in Ingolstadt pendeln könnten.
Dieser Meinung ist beispielsweise Harry Wagner;
Professor für "Automotive & Mobility Management"
an der Technischen Hochschule Ingolstadt.
In einem weiteren Schritt könnten elektrifizierte
Flugtaxis ohne Pilot schon 2035 auch in städtischen
Gebieten unterwegs sein.
Wagner zufolge könnte ein serien-fertiges
Flugtaxi bis zu einer halben Million Euro
kosten.
Gefördert wird diese Idee, die den Verkehr
tatsächlich revolutionieren könnte, von
der Politik.
Denn die Europäische Union hat genau diese
Initiative mit dem Namen “Urban Air Mobility”
ins Leben gerufen und Ingolstadt ist eine
der Modellregionen.
Weitere 14 europäische Kommunen beteiligen
sich, unter anderem Hamburg, Brüssel und
Toulouse.
Und nicht nur die Politik und die Luftfahrtindustrie
an solchen Projekten interessiert, sondern
auch die Auto-Branche selbst.
Deutlich wird das beispielsweise an dem Start-up
“Volocopter” aus Bruchsal, das ein Projekt
am Frankfurter Flughafen plant und auch mit
“Daimler” zusammenarbeitet.
Von hier könnten Passagiere mit einem “Volocopter”
ins Stadtzentrum und zurück gebracht werden
- und das voll elektrisch.
Auf der Website von “Volocopter” heißt
es: “18 leise Rotoren, einfachste Bedienung
per Joystick und ein Höchstmaß an Ausfallsicherheit
durch redundante Auslegung: Der Volocopter
2X macht aus der Vision „Fliegen für Jedermann“
Realität.
Kein Verbrennungsmotor, kein Krach, keine
komplizierte Mechanik.
Einfach einsteigen, losfliegen und entspannt
ankommen.
Willkommen im neuen Mobilitätskonzept der
Gegenwart”.
Laut einer Studie der Unternehmensberatung
“Roland Berger” hat das Start-up damit
genau den richtigen Riecher bewiesen.
Demnach entwickeln insgesamt 75 Unternehmen
auf der ganzen Welt Passagier-Drohnen.
Und in anderen Städten wie Los Angeles, Dubai
oder Singapur könnte es demnach schon 2020
Pilotprojekte mit kommerziellen Passagier-Drohnen
geben.
Dabei ist de Transport von Passagieren nur
ein Einsatzgebiet unter Vielen.
Denn auch Waren könnten so von A nach B gebracht
werden und auch die Sicherheitsüberwachung
von Bahnstrecken beispielsweise könnte durch
solche neuartigen Fluggeräte erfolgen.
Welche Fluggeräte sich dann letztendlich
durchsetzen, ist zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt noch
nicht zu sagen.
Vorstellbar sind laut der Fachleute Hybrid-Konstruktionen,
Multi- und Quadro-Copter, Kippflügler, Senkrechtstarter
- mit und ohne Piloten.
Harry Wagner schaut optimistisch in die Zukunft.
Er rechnet damit, dass es unbemannte Flugtaxis
in der Luft früher geben wird als das völlig
autonome Fahren auf der Straße mit Level
5.
Gemeint ist damit das völlig autonome Fahren,
bei dem das Fahrzeug komplett alle Fahrfunktionen
übernimmt.
Doch eine wichtige Voraussetzung dabei sei,
dass Unfälle in der Luft in jedem Fall verhindert
werden.
Dazu Wagner: “Es darf nichts passieren,
sonst wirft uns das um Jahre zurück".
So oder so: Bevor Fluggeräte ohne Piloten
kommerziell in die Luft gehen, müssen europäische
Vorschriften her.
“Airbus” selbst rechnet damit erst Mitte
des kommenden Jahrzehnts - und zwar frühestens.
Wie funktionieren selbstfahrende Autos?
Anklicken, anschauen und Doktor Whatson abonnieren.
Bis dann, bleibt dran!